اهلا بكم مشاهدينا طبعا مازلنا مستمرين مع
العربيه في هذه التغطيه للاشتباكات
الحاصله في السودان اربع ساعات على دخول
هذه الهدنه حيز التنفيذ لكن مع وقف
التنفيذ فلا جديد على ارض الميدان في
السودان طرف الصراع ما زالا يشتبكان وان
انخفضت الوتيره قليلا لكن هذا لا يعني
نجاح الهدنه المعلنه حتى الان وهو ما
اكدته كل من واشنطن والامم المتحده على
الارض الاشتباكات اشتدت بمحيط مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه في العاصمه
الخرطوم مع اتهام كل طرف للاخر بخرق
الهدنان فيما اعلن الجيش السوداني اعتقال
قائد قوه الدعم السريع في مروي
[موسيقى]
من الخرطوم ينضم الى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا الوضع الان
ماذا عن هذه الهدنه هل هناك التزام فيها
ام لا
نعم بالنسبه للهدنه لم يتم الالتزام بها
بكل تاكيد وهناك كثير من الاشكاليات
المتعلقه بهذه الهدنه انه منذ انطلاق هذه
الهدنه هناك العديد من
الضحايا للاسف في مختلف
المناطق هنا في ولايه الخرطوم في كوبر سقط
احد لكبار السن هناك طلق ناري كذلك مقذوف
وقع في منزل ثلاث ضحايا كذلك في الجريف
الشرق ايضا مقذوف اخر في مدينه الصافيه في
احد المنازل احرق هذا المنزل بالكامل
ليس هناك اي ضحايا والحمد لله كل هذه
الامور جاءت بعد اعلان هذه الهدنه ايضا في
سماء الخرطوم كانت تحلق طائرات للقوات
الجويه السودانيه
وايضا كان هناك مضادات للطائرات من قوات
الدعم السريع وكل هذا بعد الهدنه مما يفهم
الاشتباكات خلال ساعات النهار ام شعرتم
بانه هذه الوتيره خفت الى حد ما
هي هذه هي ذات الوتيره التي تعلو وتنخفض
احيانا يعني تعلو احيانا وتنخفض احيانا
بين الفينه والاخرى في هذه الفترات بذات
الوتيره في يوم امس لكن
فقط
المواطنون حقيقه الذين التقينا بهم والذين
يتواصلون معنا كذلك يشعرون بالقلق من هذه
الهدنه التي اخترقت ولم يلتزم بها الطرفان
حتى الان
الاتهامات ما زالت متبادله بين الاطراف
المتصارعه بان كل طرف هو من لا يلتزم بهذه
الهدنه
نعم بكل تاكيد
كل طرف يرسل لللوم على الاخر دعم السريع
كان قد قال لنا القوات السودانيه هي من
اخترقت الهدنه
وايضا جاءت القوات السودانيه هو من انتهك
هذه الهدنه المواطنون شكوا في اماكن عده
من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم من السقوط
العشوائي للقذائف كذلك مشتى انواعها على
منازلهم وثقت الكاميرات العديد من هذه
الاحداث وقد ذهبنا كذلك الى احدها وهو في
منطقه الصافيه نقلنا ذلك الحدث كل هذا يدل
على ان هذا القصف العشوائي بهذه الطريقه
يشكل خطرا على حياه المواطنين الى لم
يتدخل الجيش السوداني لحسم مثل هذه
الاعمال طيب سالم بالنسبه ايضا
للمستشفيات في الخرطوم ما هو وضعها يعني
كانت تعاني وكان هناك نداءات كثيره من كل
المؤسسات الطبيه ان كان السودانيه ام
الدوليه بان هناك نقص في في وصول
المعدات لهذه المستشفيات ايضا تعاني من
موضوع قطع الكهرباء ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل
حول وضع المستشفيات الان
وضع المستشفيات للاسف سيء جدا قبل قليل او
قبل تقريبا ساعه من الان تعرض مستشفى في
ظل بالاسلحه الثقيله معدل الغاز المركزي
صهاريج المياه الرئيسيه المخصصه لمرضى
غسيل الكلى هنالك الوقود نتيجه الانقطاع
التيار الكهربائي منذ الامس من الساعه
الثامنه صباحا ايضا هنالك شحف الاغذيه
والادويه والمسالكات الطبيه رغم ان
المستشفى به عدد كبير من المرضى في
العنايات والغرف وهناك مناشدات من وزاره
الصحه الاتحاديه تناشد الجهات المسؤوله
بالتدخل العاجل لاخلاء المستشفى لعدم توفر
الامن هذا قبل قليل كان هذا المستشفى اخر
المستشفيات التي تعرضت لهذه الانتهاكات
مستشفى تضل قبله كذلك مستشفى الزيتونه
تعرض ايضا
لقصر ايضا قبل تقريبا
ساعات كذلك كل هذه الامور تجعل على
المستشفيات حقيقه مؤسف للغايه اذا لم
تتدخل الدوله لوقف اولا هذا العنف ومن ثم
اجلاء الموجودين الان في داخل المستشفى
وتوفير الامن لهم وحتى الذين المرضى الذين
في داخل العنايات المركزه الدفاع المدني
كان يتحدث مع العربيه في الساعه الماضيه
بانه اذا تمكن سيبدا بالنزول على الارض
لاحصاء الخسائر ايضا احصاء الجرحى
الضحايا هل تمكن حتى الان الدفاع المدني
من النزول الى الشوارع
نعمل الدفاع المدني هو قد كان جاء هذا
الامر من وزير الداخليه
الذي شكل اليه لتوزيع المساعدات الانسانيه
وحفظ
وتراس هذه
الاليه هي الدفاع المدني ايضا هذه الاليه
يجب ان تعمل بشكل فوري وتبدا في مهام
متابعه وصول واستلام المساعدات الانسانيه
والاغاثيه والعمل على توفير كل الاحتياجات
الضروريه من المواد الغذائيه ومواد
الايواء كذلك التعامل مع الجثث والمنتشره
في الطرقات حفظها في المشاريع كذلك اضافه
الى اسعافها المصابين والجرحى وترحيلهم
للمستشفيات والمراكز العلاجيه والاشراف
على ترحيل الكوادر الطبيه كل هذه المهام
تنتظر
الدفاع المدني الدفاع المدني يتحدث على
انه سيبدا بالاطلاع في هذه المهام لكن الى
الان لم يبدا بعد لكن ينتظر المواطن
السوداني كثير من
اعجبني ولكن اصوات الاشتباكات
والقصف بالمدفعيه واطلاق النار يعني يطغى
على صوتك ان استمع الى الصوت الطبيعي ومن
ثم اعود اليك
اذا المشاهدينا نستمع وهناك استمرار
لاصوات الاشتباكات في الخرطوم هذا القصف
متقطع يعني في بعض الاحيان تكون الاصوات
عاليه جدا وتكون وتيره القصف مرتفعه وفي
احيان اخرى تخف وتيره هذه او هذا القصف
وسماع طلقات الناريه وايضا القذائف سالم
اعود اليك تفضل
نعم ايضا في في الحديث عن المسار الانساني
هذه القصف للمستشفيات دفع وزاره الصحه
الاتحاديه لانها تناسق الجهات المسؤوله
بالتدخل السريع في هذه المساله لان
استمرار هذا القصف على المستشفيات وعدم
توفير المواد اللوجستيه التي يحتاجها بهذا
التي تحتاجها المستشفيات اضافه الى تامين
الطرق المؤديه للمستشفيات لضمان وصول
الكوادر الطبيه لهذه المستشفيات ربما تم
بكارثه صحيه في البلاد خاصه مع هذه
الاحداث التي نتابع فيها العديد من
المصابين والجرحى وغير ذلك هذا الامر
يحتاج الى تدخل سريع حقيقه من الدوله يضاف
الى ذلك المسؤوليات التي تقع ايضا على
ولايه الخرطوم التي كانت في وقت سابق
اعلنت عن انها ستبدا مباشره في عمليه
اصلاح محطات المياه
لاجل ان يتساب المياه للجميع ستبدا حسب
ولايه الخرطوم ستبدا من يوم غد في عمليه
اصلاح هذه المياه بحسب المصادر التي اكدت
لنا ذلك لكن ما زال المواطنون ينتظرون كل
هذه الامور المتعلقه بالمسار الانساني وهو
مهم جدا حتى لا تذهب البلاد الى كارثه
انسانيه حقيقيه نعم على كل حال هناك بيان
الان للجيش السوداني يقول بان قوات الجيش
السوداني تسيطر على كامل منطقه شرق النيل
اذا ايضا على مطار مروي بشكل كامل بيان
للجيش السوداني اذا يقول بانه القوات
الجيش السوداني تسيطر على كامل منطقه شرق
النيل وايضا على مطار مروي بشكل كامل على
كل حال ايضا لدينا فيديوهات ايضا الان
تظهر
اعتقال او توقيف قائد قوه الدعم السريع في
مروي يمكن ان نتابعها سويا لو سمحتوا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اللغه
مبروك والله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مبروك والله
صلوا صلوا
[موسيقى]
يا جماعه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تبعنا هذا الفيديو الذي
متداول طبعا بان الجيش السوداني قام
باعتقال قائد قوه الدعم السريع في مروي
ايضا بيان للجيش السوداني تحدث بانه سيطر
على مطار مروي بشكل كامل وعلى منطقه شرق
النيل على كل حال ساعود الى سالم الهاشمي
مراسل العربيه الان ليطلعنا ايضا على
الاوضاع في الخرطوم سالم ما كنا نتحدث عن
الوضع الانساني عن الوضع السيء جدا
للمستشفيات ولكن هناك ايضا امر اخر عند
بدايه هذه الاشتباكات هناك طلاب كانوا
عالقين في بعض المدارس في بعض الجامعات هل
تامن لهم اي ممرات امنيه حتى يستطيع
الخروج اما زالوا عالقين
نعم كان قد تحدث الجيش السوداني عن
الجلاءه لاربعه وثمانين من العالقين
بجامعه الخرطوم وانه اجل العالقين لمدينه
بحري وان الجيش كذلك يتصدى لمحاوله اعتذار
بموقع الشندي اثناء عمليه الاجلاء بالنسبه
للاربعه وثمانين من العالقين في جامعه
الخرطوم
هؤلاء العالقين كانوا موجودين في داخل
الجامعه وكان قد وقتل واحد منهم ودفن في
داخل الجامعه وهذا يعد يعني مشهد غريب
حقيقه على
الشعب السوداني عدم القدره حتى على يعني
تحريك الجثه الى المقابر وهذا الامر يعني
ادى الى يعني يؤدي الى الشوارع مغلقه الى
الحد الذي لا يستطيع فيه انسان ان يحمل
ميت لديه ليوصله الى المقابر حقيقه امر
المؤسف الشوارع فعلا هي بهذا الحد من
الاغلاق لكن على كل حال
هذا الامر يعني يحتاج الى ان تكون هنالك
هدنه او التركيز على المسار الانساني من
اجل
الوصول فيه الى حلول حقيقيه حتى يستطيع
الجيش السوداني حمايه المواطنين وتوفير
الامن لهم
سالم بالنسبه ايضا
لتركيز الاشتباكات على كل حال ايضا
دعنا نتابع هذه الصور
لحظه اعلان السيطره على مطار مروي اذا هذه
الصور ايضا تصلنا الان
تظهر سيطره الجيش السوداني على مطار مروي
وكان منذ قليل البيان للجيش السوداني تحدث
بانه سيطر بالكامل على مطار مروي هذا
الفيديو المتداول الان والذي وصلنا للتو
يقال بانه هو لحظه سيطره الجيش السوداني
على مطار مروى
والحمد لله كلهم
قاعدين متواجدين معنا الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
كلهم
بعدين متواجدين معنا الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
ده الجواز
الحمد لله كلهم
[موسيقى]
قاعدين متواجدين معنا الحمد لله
قفز الجماعه
اذا تابعنا سويا هذا الفيديو الذي يقال
بانه لحظه سيطره الجيش السوداني على مطار
مروي سالم اعود اليك بالنسبه ايضا للوضع
الانساني في الخرطوم نريد ان نركز ايضا
على هذا الامر
منذ اربعه ايام والناس يعني هي غير
لا تستطيع ان تخرج الى الشوارع المحل
التجاريه كلها مقفله ايضا هناك
نقص في المواد الغذائيه كيف يتدبر الناس
امرهم خلال الاربعه ايام هذه
هذا الامر هو بالفعل من الامور المهمه
والحساسه كذلك الحديث عن الوضع الانساني
وايضا انهيار المنظومه الصحيه وهي التي
يعني بدات في الانهيار حقيقه
وهذا ما اكدته وزاره الصحه حينما قالت ان
القطاع الصحيح الخرطوم مواجها انهيارا
بسبب تضاؤل امدادات الطاقه المستشفيات في
حاجه لاستدامه عمل المولدات الاحتياطيه من
اجل تقديم الخدمات الصحيه الاساسيه ايضا
هنالك نقص حاد في اكياس الدم في كل ولايات
السودان ايضا وزاره الصحه تدعو لايجاد حل
مستدام لنقص امدادات الطاقه في المرافق
الصحيه وكافه الدم وايضا في ولايه الخرطوم
هناك اشكاليات وحاجه في ما يتعلق بالدعم
اللوجستي ووصول الاطباء
للمستشفيات خاصه وان الطرق تكاد تكون
مغلقه الكوادر الطبيه
الموجوده في المستشفيات لا تغطيك وايضا
انقطاع المياه كذلك من عدد من المستشفيات
كلها عوامل تجعل القطاع الصحي مهددا
بالانهيار يضاف الى ذلك في المسار
الانساني انقطاع المياه هو القصف ام ماذا
نعم هو القصف بالضبط كان هو كما اكدت
اليوم ولايه الخرطوم ان محطات المياه كانت
قد قصفت وتحتاج الى معالجات واكدت ولايه
الخرطوم انها ستبدا في معالجه هذه المحطات
ومعالجه هذه المحطات طالبت فيها
ولايه الخرطوم ممثله في واليها بانه يجب
ان توفر حمايه للطاقم الذي سيقوم بعمليه
الصيانه حتى لا يكون مهددا مع هذه الاوضاع
وسيناقشون مع الجيش السوداني كيفيه توفير
الحمايه
لهؤلاء الذين سيقومون بالصيانه من اجل
ارجاع الامداد المائي لولايه الخرطوم
فكذلك موضوع نقص بعض المواد المتعلقه
بالمواد الغذائيه في بعض السلع هناك اصبحت
فيها ندره على انه نلاحظ الان بدات تعود
الصفوف
للافر الخبز في ولايه الخرطوم بدات تعود
هذه الصفوف مره اخرى بعد ان اختفت لفتره
من الزمن الان بدات تعود بسبب ندره الدقيق
كذلك هناك ايضا مشكله اخرى في ندره في
المواد البترونيه غالب محطات الوقود مغلقه
نلاحظ الان ايضا محطات الوقود فيها سقوف
طويله جدا وهي لا تعمل هذا هو اللافت
للانتباه يعني هذه الصفوف من التيارات ولا
توجد محطه تعمل هذا ما يدعو للاستغراب
حقيقه هذه محطات الوقود اليوم الرابع وهي
لا تعمل بكل تاكيد ستكون هناك ازدحام لان
كل هذه السيارات وحتى عربات النقل العام
كل هذه لم
منذ اربعه ايام لم تصل لهذه المحطات
لتزويد العربات وغيرها بالوقود شكرا لك
حتى الان مراسل العربيه سالم الهاشمي
دائما سنكون معك لتطلعنا على كل التفاصيل
وعلى كل التطورات الحاصله في الخرطوم شكرا
لك
والان مشاهدينا سنتوقف مع هذا الفيديو
الذي يقول الجيش السوداني بانه هو يظهر
اسرى من الدعم السريع اذا هذا الفيديو
الذي سنتابعه لا ادري اذا اصبح جاهزا يقول
الجيش السوداني بان هذا الفيديو هو
لاسرى طبعا تابعه للدعم السريع نتابع
دواء من واجباتنا نحن فيكم
والحيله لكم
محمد داود
طبعا
واشكر الجيش الفرقه ثلاثه
المشكله والخير
يلبس ملكيه احد
ناكل ولا نشرب مصايمين
الحمد لله ناسونه
تماما مرتاحين الاهل في الجنينه ولايه
الجنينه
والله الحمد لله مطمئنين
السلام عليكم
الحمد لله كويس مصطفى
من ولايه جنوب
مستجدين قوات الدعم السريع في معسكر ذري
وبعد ما استمرينا فتره من الايام
اذا مشاهدينا منذ بدايه هذه الساعه حتى
الان هناك بعض الاخبار العاجله هناك بيان
للجيش السوداني في بدايه هذه الساعه تحدث
عن السيطره على مطار مروراوي بشكل كامل
على منطقه شرق النيل بشكل كامل ايضا بس
هذه الفيديوهات لاسرى يقول بانها من قوه
الدعم السريع كما بث ايضا فيديوهات
لاعتقال
قائد قوات الدعم السريع
والان سنذهب الى زميلنا نزار بقداوي من
مروي
ليطلعنا على ابرد التطورات هناك ولكن
دعونا نستمع الى صوت الطبيعي لهذه
الاشتباكات الحاصله الان في الخرطوم وطبعا
هذه الصوره خاصه بقناه العربيه حيث تتركز
كاميرا العربيه في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تابعنا هذا الصوت الطبيعي
للاشتباكات الحاصله في الخرطوم كما تابعنا
كان هناك اطلاق سماع عدوي اطلاق نار ايضا
قذائف من الاسلحه الثقيله ايضا سمعنا
مضادات للطيران هذه الصوره مركزه خاصه
بكاميرا العربيه تنقل لنا بالصوت والصوره
كل ما يجري في الخرطوم اما الان دعونا
نذهب الى زميلنا في مروي مراسل العربيه
نزار بداوي نظام نزار اهلا بك معنا الجيش
السوداني يتحدث بانه سيطره بالكامل على
مطار مروي ايضا بس بعض الفيديوهات
الاعتقال قائد قوه الدعم السريع هناك
على كل حال هل يمكن ان تعطينا تفاصيل ما
يجري الان في مروي
ميسون نذكر ونعيب بتفاصيل وبمشاهد وبما
حدث خلال ساعات النهار والمساء هنا في
مروي شمال السودان هذا اليوم بدا
باشتباكات متقطعه ثم استمعنا الى قصف من
قبل المدفعيه الثقيله من قبل القوات
المسلحه الجيش السوداني في عمق القاعده
وفي عمق مطار مروي الذي تمركزت فيه قوات
الدعم السريع خلال اليومين الماضيين بعدها
مباشره ميسون ورده المعلومات بان الجيش
حسب المصادر اجبر قوات الدعم السريعه على
مغادره القاعده والمطار اتجهت هذه القوه
في نحو 120 الى 130 سياره اللي اتبع
الرباعي وعلى متنها جنود لقوات الدعم
السريع اتجهوا جنوبا من قاعده مروي الجويه
صوب منطقه الملتقى والقرى المحيطه بهذه
المنطقه
معي
يبدو باننا فقدنا الاتصال بزميلنا نزار
بقداوي على كل حال نحن مازلنا نتابع على
شاشه العربيه هذه الصور لمحيط مبنى قياده
الجيش
وايضا لمطار مروي
ونتابع ايضا في هذه الصوره الخرطوم كيف
كانت اليوم حيث عملت النيران كانت تغطي
سماء الخرطومه كافه ساعات النهار وايضا
الليل منذ قليل كنا تبعنا بالصوت الطبيعي
للانفجارات واصوات الاسلحه الثقيله في
الخرطوم نعود ونذكر بانه على الرغم من
اعلان تهدئه وكان يجب ان تبدا الساعه
السادسه بتوقيت السودان ولكن مع هذه
الاصوات التي نتابعها سويا هذا التاكيد
بانه هذه الهدنه صحيح دخلت حيز التنفيذ
ولكن لم تنفذ حتى الان حتى ان
الامم المتحده تحدثت بانه هذه الهدنه لم
يتم الالتزام بها حتى الان وكل الدول
الاقليميه وايضا المجتمع الدولي من خلال
متابعته لما يحصل في الخرطوم
يعني يشعرون بانه ليس هناك من نيه حتى
الان بوقف القصف حتى ان المبعوث الاممي
الى السودان كانت حدث بانه ليس لديه
انطباع بان طرفين نزاع
يريدون او يرغبون يرغبان في هذه الوساطه
او في هذه الهدنه ان صح التعبير
دعونا نستمع لصوت الطبيعي
اذا الجيش السوداني منذ قليل كان اعلن في
بيان بانه سيطر على كامل مطار مروي وعلى
كامل منطقه شرق النيل
ونعود ونذكر ايضا بانه الهدنه التي كان
يفترض ان تدخل الساعه السادسه بتوقيت
الخرطوم ولكن اصوات القذائف وهذه الاسلحه
الثقيله التي نتابعها منذ ساعات ما زالت
مستمره ايضا كان زميلنا سالم تحدث بانه
هناك وضع سيء جدا
للمستشفيات في الخرطوم بسبب القصف يعني
الاطباء يعني لا يستطيعون الوصول الى
المستشفيات هناك نقص في الطاقم الطبي ايضا
هناك نقص في المعدات الطبيه
وتحدث عن ان هناك طوابير طويله على افران
الخبز وعلى ايضا محطات الوقود وهذه
الاوضاع المتوتره ما زالت مستمره في كافه
الولايات التي تشهد اشتباكات منذ اربعه
ايام
يعود الينا الان نزار كنا نتحدث عن كيف
يمكن ان تلخص لنا هذا اليوم في مروي وكيف
هي الاوضاع الان
نعم ذكرنا ونذكر الان بان هذا اليوم بدا
باشتباكات متقطعه بالمدفعيه الثقيله من
قبل الجيش في مواجهه قوات الدعم السريعه
التي كانت قد تمركزت داخل محيط وقلب
القائد الجويه والمطار
بعدها مباشره بعد تكثيف هذا القصف المدفعي
بحسب الجيش اضطرت هذه القوات التابعه
للدعم السريع ان تغادر قاعده مروي الجويه
متوجهه جنوبا صوب منطقه الملتقى حينها اكد
لنا شهود عيان بان نحو 120 سياره للدعم
السريع اتمركزت في هذه المنطقه وبدات
بالتوجه جنوبا وفور توجهها شاهدوا طلعه
جويه للقوات الجويه ضربت هذه الطائرات
ركل السيارات الذي يحمل جنود الدعم السريع
المصادر ايضا اكدت التضرر ما بين 40 الى
50 سياره تابعه لقوات الدعم سريع وبقيه
السيارات انتشرت وتفرقت في عديد الاوديه
والشوارع
والمشاريع الزراعيه في هذه المنطقه
الشاسعه المتسعه صوب العاصمه الخرطوم وصوب
ولايه نهر النيل وصوب ايضا شمالا الولايات
الشماليه الان الوضع في مدينه مروي هذه
تماما لا نسمع اي اطلاق للنار لا نسمع اي
صوت للمدفعيه الثقيله الجيش بحسب البيان
يسيطر الان على مداخل ومخارج هذا المطار
هنالك ارتكازات داخل مدينه مروي
الاوضاع داخل المستشفيات على ما هي عليه
مصاب الجيش داخل المستشفيات تلقون العلاج
المواطنون في حاله توتر لكن هذا التوتر
الان يبدو انه في طريقه الى ان يقف قليلا
بعد ان استمعوا الى هذه الاخبار التي تؤكد
وتدلل على ان الجيش بسط سيطرته على كامل
الاجزاء مطار وق اعده مروي الجويه هل كل
شيء مقفل في مروي يعني محطات وقود افران
محل تجاريه ام يستطيع الناس في مروي تامين
بعض الاحتياجات
بحكم الوضعيه المعقده والملتبسه للعمليه
العسكريه هنا في مطار مروي
لحسن الحظ كما يقول المواطنون والمدنيون
بان المدينه لم تكن جزءا من هذه العمليه
العسكريه وانما فقط ارضيه المطار والقاعده
هما من كان تحلي هذه العمليه الوضعيه او
التداعيات التي خلفتها الاشتباكات خلفت
بعض التوتر والخوف والقلق من ان من ان
تمتد هذه الاشتباكات الى داخل المدينه لكن
لم يحدث هذا مطلقا
لكن نتيجه ايضا لهذه التداعيات تخوف
المواطنون تم اغلاق السوق الكبير الرئيس
في هذه المدينه مدينه مروي المحاله
التجاريه مغلقه لكن في الاحياء الان بدات
تعود اليها الحياه
الخدمات متوفره خدمات الكهرباء متوفره
خدمات المياه متوفره الطرق الثالثه ليس من
متاريس عسكريه ولا نقاط تفليش بالعبور
غربا نحو مدينه كريمه الامور هادئه تماما
الحياه على طبيع على وثيرتها ايضا في
دنقله في بقيه القرى في بقيه المدن الامور
تمضي نحو الافضل وهذا ما يتمناه مواطني
هذه المنطقه
على كل حال نزار ايضا يمكن القول بانه
الوضع المدني في مروي الان هو جيد
وهناك حاله من الهدوء نعود ونذكر نزار
اسمح لي ان تبقى معي لنذكر ايضا
للوضع الان في الخرطوم حيث حقيقه
الاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره على الرغم من
الحديث عن هدنه وكان يجب ان تبدا هذه
الهدنه الساعه السادسه ودخلت حيز التنفيذ
الساعه السادسه ولكن لما يتم تنفيذ هذه
الهدنه ومنذ ساعات ونحن نتابع هذا الصوت
للاشتباكات واصوات الاسلحه الثقيله نستمع
الى الصوت الطبيعي
ضبابيه المشهد في السودان مشاهدينا التي
يسهم فيها بشكل كبير دخان القذائف تنبع من
سيل الاخبار المضلله والكاذبه انتصارات
اعلن عنها الطرفان وصفت بالهشحين
وبالكاذبه احيانا دون معرفه الجانب المحق
لكن المعلوم ان المعارك تتركز في هذه
المناطق اي العاصمه الخرطوم ومروي وام
درمان كما نتابع في هذه الخريطه الخرطوم
مهد هذه المواجهه المسلحه ان صح التعبير
شهدت اشتعال الشراره الاولى ففيها تتمركز
المواقع الاستراتيجيه والحيويه طبعا
يتنازع الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع للسيطره
عليها الاشتباكات اي ان احتدمت على تخوم
القصر الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه وقياده قوات الدعم السريع
وايضا هناك مطارات عسكريه ومدنيه تركزت
فيها لكن التركيز كان على محيط القياده
للمقر حقيقه اهميه مركزيه لوقوعه وسط
العاصمه فهو يتكون من خمسه ابنيه يضم
وزاره الدفاع وقيادات القوات البريه
والبحريه والجويه والاستخبارات العسكريه
ما يعني ان الالمام بكافه الجوانب
العسكريه والامنيه في السودان ايضا في
جنوبي الخرطوم وتحديدا قاعده النجوم
الجويه التي نتابعها هنا اظهرت فيديوهات
احراق قوات الدعم السريعه لعدد من مروحيات
الجيش السوداني فيها الان دعوني انتقل الى
مطار
الثوم الذي يشكل محور تصادم اعلامي من
الجهتين واخر الروايات تتحدث عن سيطره
قوات حميتي عليه مع استمرار الاشتباكات من
وسط السودان الى شماله ومطار اخر يشهد
احتدام المعارك وهو مروري مروي الجيش اعلن
قبل ساعات سيطرته على معظمه والان قبل
قليل كنا تابعنا اخبار عاجله على شاشه
العربيه يؤكد الجيش بانه سيطر على كامل
هذا المطار مع انسحاب اعداد كبيره طبعا من
قوات حميتي ياتي كل ذلك في وقت تتواصل
عمليات الكرب والفرد في مدينه ام درمان
ايضا اشتباكات عنيفه مع تحليق مستمر
للطيران الحربي في سمائها
[موسيقى]
انت عارف
لا حول ولا
[موسيقى]
قوه
يا احمد
احداث متسارعه يشهدها السودان في رابع
ايام الاشتباكات الداميه بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع لكن الرؤيه النهائيه بشان
الطرف العسكري الذي سيبسط سيطرته على
الارض لم تتضح حتى هذه اللحظه تعددت
الروايات بين الاطراف المتنازعه والمتضرر
واحد الشعب السوداني الذي عانى وما زال من
هذه الصراعات معدلات القتل والاصابات
تتزايد بوتيره متفاقمه والعديد من
المستشفيات خرجت عن الخدمه فبعضها ضربت
بالقذائف والبعض الاخر انقطعت عنه
الكهرباء ولا يجد للامدادات الطبيه سبيله
اذا استمر القتال سيكون هناك المزيد من
الضحايا الارقام التي حصلت عليها لم يتم
تاكيدها نحن نعتمد على معلومات من الاطباء
السودانيين ومن المستشفيات حتى الان قتل
ما لا يقل عن 185 شخصا وا اكثر من 1800
شخص بمن فيهم مدنيون وعناصر الجيش تحرك
صعب يواجه السكان في ظل القصف الجوي
والاشتباكات العنيفه على الارض
واماكن متفرقه احتجز فيها السودانيون منذ
بدايه الاشتباكات ومنها الجامعات غير
المجهزه لحال كهذه والعديد من هؤلاء
المحتجزين حاولوا الخروج للعوده الى
منازلهم اثناء هدنه وقف اطلاق النار التي
دعت اليها بعثه الامم المتحده الا ان
الاطراف المتصارعه لم تلتزم بها رغم
التعهدات باحترامها
احنا حوالي 88
نفر مننا عشرين عامل فيهم كبار السن
وفي حوالي خمسه طالبات المعارك في السودان
احدثت نكسه غذائيه بسبب صعوبه التنقل
وارتفاع الاسعار وسط تعليق العشرات من
برامج المساعدات الانسانيه بعد ان نهبت
الامدادات ودمرت مساعدات لا يمكنني اعطائك
اي ارقام محدده حول قيمه الممتلكات
المسروقه او الامدادات المنهوبه او حتى
المساعدات التي دمرت بسبب القتال كما قلت
في وقت سابق في هذه الظروف لا يمكن ان
يحدث اي توصيل للمساعدات بشكل اساسي تمديد
وقلق امميان واطراف اقليميه ودوليه تقف
على خط الازمه التي ساحت ثالثه اكبر بلد
افريقي الا ان تلك المساعي والمحاولات
المتعدده لم تجد اذانا صاغيه حتى الان
سلطان العيبان العربيه
في الولايات يمكن تم تسيطر عليها تماما
نحن نسيطر الان على القياده العامه
بالكامل تسيطر على مطار الخرطوم الرئاسي
ومقانون العسكري ان هذا تمر بالنسبه
للمبادرات نحن نرحب بكل مبادره لكن الان
الماركه
نحن ليس لدينا مشكله مع قوات الشعب السريع
اثناء نفصل ما بينما يقوم به محمد حمدان
وشقيقي
وقبل ان اذهب الى ضيفي هنا في الاستوديو
دعونا نذهب الان الى اميره مصطفى عطا
المنان وهي موظفه في مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي حتى تعطينا صوره واضحه عن وضع
المستشفيات ووضع الجرحى هناك امير اهلا بك
معنا هل يمكن ان تصفي لنا وضع مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي واذا كان لديك اي
معلومات عن المستشفيات الاخرى
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
تفضل يا ست اميره هل سمعت السؤال
نعم تفضلي
انا راشد من مستشفى الخرطوم والتعليمي
خرطومه التعليمي حاليا المستشفى يشغل جميع
اللغومات الحياه
من مياه وكهرباء
وجبات للطعام
لا توجد ادويه
والكادر الطبي غير متوفر
بالناشد انه
ينقل لنا المرضى من مستشفى الخرطوم اقرب
مستشفى في جبره او ابن سينا
مع من تتصلون اميره حتى يتمكنوا من نقل
هؤلاء الجرحى هل هناك من اتصالات حتى يكون
هناك ممر امن تستطيعون بعده اخراج هؤلاء
الجرحى والمرضى من المستشفى
نعم نعم
في زملانه في المستشفى في داخل المستشفى
هم الى الان معتجزون هناك
نعم
متواصلين معهم هم الان
كان عندهم محاوله في انهم يصلحوا يعملوا
صيانه
المولد الكهربائي ولكن بدون جدوى
اذا الوضع في مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي كما
تتحدثين اميره يعني لا كهرباء ولمياه
وانتم تناشدون بنقل المرضى والجرحى من من
هذه المستشفى هل لديك اي احصائيه مثلا عن
الجرح الذين دخلوا الى مستشفى الخرطوم
التعليمي هل لديك من ارقام
ما في ارقام محدده ارقام محدده لانه في
جزء منه يتنقلوا كلهم وحاليا الموجودين
ولكن الاعداد كبيره
يعني اذا ليس لديك من احصائيه ولكن اقله
هل اعداد كبيره التي دخلت الى هذا
المستشفى
لم يدخل ليها يعني الجرحى ولكن
هم جميعهم مرضى في
غرف الاعاش
والاصابات حدثت داخل المستشفى للمواطنين
شكرا لك من المواطنين نعم شكرا لك يا
اميره مصطفى عطاء المنان وظف في مستشفى
الخرطوم التعليمي
وانضم الينا دكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى
الكاتب والمحلل في الشؤون الافريقيه دكتور
اسامه اهلا بك معنا
السودان هناك حروب كثيره وقعت على ارض
السودان يعني منذ عام 1955 حتى الان كانت
هناك اربع حروب كبيره بالاضافه الى الحروب
الصغيره التي استمرت ايام ولكن هذه الحرب
الذي تسمى الان حرب البعض يعتبرها بانها
الاخطر لماذا لان
تعيني ارجع قليلا الى 56 الى اليوم القوات
المسلحه السودانيه لم تحارب الا
السودانيين يعني لم تحارب مع حدود
السودانيه مع جهات اخرى غير السودانيين
سواء كان في جنوب السودان وقتلوا حوالي 2
مليون شخصي في هذه الحرب من الطرفين في
دارفور الحرب ايضا بين قوات المسلحه
السودانيه مع قوات هي سودانيه في
كردفان نفس الامر ولكن هذه الحرب شكلا
ومضمونا تختلف تماما لماذا لان القوات
الدعم السريع هي قوات تم انشاءها من بقرار
من القوات المسلحه نفسها او قياده القوات
المسلحه في العام
2013 و14
وتحول الى لكي تكون ضمن
الامن والاستخبارات ثم في 2017 اصبحت ضمن
قوات المسلحه جزء من القوات المسلحه
بقرار
اللي هو ضمن قرارات التكوين هذه القوات
فبالتالي الحرب كما اشر السيد رئيس مجلس
العسكري السيد بن فتاح البرهان بانه هي
تمرد
وفيما السيد محمد حمدون دوجلو
بايرى انه هذا ليس تمر او حق اذا الشكل
الحرب اختلفت باعتبار انه الحرب بين نفس
الجيش ولكن
لذلك هذه الحرب لا منتصر فيها يعني هل
سيصعب حسمها
الى حد كبير نستطيع ان نقول سيصعب حسمها
ولكن في النهايه يتم حسم هذه الحرب بمن
يستطيع ان يكون نفسه طويل قادر ان
يصبر على الوضع تماما الكل يتساءل بعد هذه
الحرب هل هذان الطرفان هاتان الشخصيتين
حمتي والبرهان واحد منهم سيستمر ان سيعود
الاثنان الى الحكم في الجيش هذا ما لا
اتمناه
ولكن اذا ما انتهت هذه الحرب ما اتوقعه
سيتم رفضهم من
الشخصيتين من المجتمع السوداني كاملا من
الشعب السوداني وربما المجتمع الدولي
باعتبارهما هما الان
جرائم حرب ترتكب في السودان بسببهم
الطرفان
الشعب السوداني الذي يموت الان باعداد
كبيره
السبب الاساسي فيه هم انانيه الطرفين كل
منهم يسعى
للوجود للجلوس على الكرسي السلطه
وطارب بعرض الحائط كلي مقررات الشعب
السوداني دكتور اسامه اسمح لي ان تبقى معي
سنذهب
لنتابع ايضا هذه الاسماء في السودان طبعا
الازمه الانسانيه هي التي تفاقمت الان في
السودان بعد حوادث قصف مستشفيات وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم وكنا تابعنا منذ قليل مع
ضيفتنا كانت تتحدث بانه الوضع في
المستشفيات وايضا زميلنا نزار
وزميلنا سالم كان يتحدث بانه هناك وضع
ماساوي في مستشفيات الخرطوم حيث شهدت
السودان طبعا شح في المستلزمات الطبيه اثر
هذه المعارك الدائره بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع دعونا نتابع تفاصيل هذا
الوضع هناك
[موسيقى]
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف قصف بالتوقيت الحرج لم
يتمكن مرضى الكلى من اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه
لكن ما ترى ايضا لم يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قدائف عشوائيه عليه
وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب ولم يسلم من
قضاء في العسكر تدمر بالكامل يعتبر من
اكبر مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها حيويه
ثمه مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء منه ابدا ايجابي بالعكس
لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم الاوضاع اكثر
واكثر
دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار لفتح
مسارات امنه لنقل المساعدات الانسانيه
للمدنيين وان تحققت لفتره فثمت تحولات
عسكريه بين حين واخر قد تجعل الحاله اكثر
ضبابيه
غذاء السالم العربيه
تعود معنا الان اميره مصطفى عطاء المنان
الموظفه في مستشفى الخرطوم التعليمي اميره
ساعود اليك اسمحي لي ان تعطينا صوره مفصله
عما يجري داخل المستشفى الان
يا اختي
الان داخل المستشفى
الحركه داخل المستشفى صعبه صعبه جدا
بالنسبه للشظائع
الشظائع
من البتا من الاطلاق النار المتبادل
والمستشفى لموقعه ذاته موقعه وسط منطقه
الحرب
هل يمكن ان اين تقع هذه المستشفى بالضبط
طبع
طبع غرب غرب غرب القياده
الجهه الغربيه للقياده القياده العامه
يعني انتم في محيط مبنى قياده الجيش
ايوه في محيط في محيط المبنى وفي وفي مرمى
في مرمى النار
طب اين تجلسون الان هل هناك هل هناك من
مكان الى حد ما امن في المستشفى تستطيعون
وضع المرضى فيه والطاقم الطبي المتواجد
هناك
لا يوجد مكان امن هو العنابر
مجموعه من العنابر
ويوجد مصابين مصابين من
الشدرايه
بتدخل على المستشفى
اميره المصابين داخل هذه المستشفى بسبب
القصف الذي يحيط بالمستشفى وليسوا مصابين
من خارج المستشفى واتوا اليها
نعم نعم من داخل المستشفى
لا يوجد يعني طريقه
لجلب المصابين من خارج المستشفى
موقعه في وسط وسط
وسط المرمى مرمى النيران
طب هل هناك حاليا هي متوقفه خالص هل هناك
من مولدات في المستشفى هل هناك من من
مولدات تستطيعون تشغيلها في المستشفى
مولدات كهرباء اقله لا توجدات كهرباء لا
توجد
لا توجد اي اي مقاومات
[موسيقى]
للحياه في في المستشفى
لذلك انا اعطيت
لكم الناس الصائمين ما فطروا الى الان
ما فطروا لكن يجمع لا يوجد
مع الفطور الفايمين ما فطروا المرضى
معتلوا شيء من الصباح
في الجروبات لم نجد اي استجابه لله الى
الان
اشكرك يا اميره مصطفى عطا المنان الموظفه
في مستشفى الخرطومه التعليمي التي تناشد
بان تتم مساعده هذه المستشفى لانها تقع في
محيط قياده الجيش
والقصف حول هذه المستشفى سبب باصابات داخل
المستشفى شكرا لك كما اشكر ايضا ضيفنا
دكتور اسامه احمد المصطفى الكاتب والمحلل
في الشؤون الافريقيه هذه هي التغطيه
مشاهدينا مستمره ولكن ننتقل الان الى
الزميل طاهر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات